each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay thanks Carla yes so I'm Kenji
together I've been at microsoft research
about a year now I was at Southampton
University before actually an aerospace
engineer by trade so if you want to know
how to design a Formula One car come
talk to me lots of my students do that
now for their day job and I did a lot of
work in computing high performance
computing than cloud computing
scientific computing so I ended up here
and so I mean Scarlett's team having a
lot of fun fantastic people in lab
fantastic research going on so I'm going
to give a talk about functional first
programming okay so how many of you've
done functional programming haskell
oakham all that kind of thing okay if
you've you've quite a lot of you cool
how many of you have used F sharp a half
few of you okay cool so I'm going to
talk about functional programming okay
and how that fits basically in kind of
real-world applications but also in
research what I would say is I used to
supervise a lot of PhD students and i
wish i was doing my PhD again because
it's a fantastic time in your lives
basically where you know when you're
doing your sort of degree undergraduate
MSC your kind of directed in what you do
in terms you have lectures and
assignments and exams and that kind of
thing when you do you PhD you're given a
bit of freedom depending on your
supervisor okay if your supervisor has a
whip and kind of cracks it and you know
so a lot of the projects I I used to run
with companies like Airbus a Formula One
team so they're set deliverables in
terms of you know you have to do this
for the company but most that's quite
unusual i think most phd's you have a
fair bit of a leeway so what i would say
is you know if you were how many of you
in your first year which is kind of
kicking off okay so a lot of you just
starting out the first year is a great
time for exploration okay you can learn
lots of things there are lots of
opportunities like the summer school you
know lots of things that you can learn
and so that's kind of how I've kind of
pictures talk danse I'm who is the the
sort of father r f sharp has given lots
of talks about this and I've sort of
combined a few of those to try and give
you a
flavor for what we call functional first
programming okay so you know functional
programming you know we can we there are
definitions of that and there are pure
functional languages like Haskell there
are multi-paradigm languages like f
sharp or like Scala and so here we're
actually talking about functional first
so it's a sharps a sort of hybrid
multi-paradigm and then the most recent
developments in f-sharp around this
information rich programming so I'll get
on to that in the second half of the
talk in terms of how f sharp with its
new version which is just sort of
shipping in release candidate now and
shipping later in the year allows us to
really tap into particularly sort of
information on the web so hopefully you
can kind of look at this with an open
mind and I will plug is that Thomas
Petra check here who is one of our PhD
students who happens to also be a
microsoft MVP so we have these people
called MVPs most valuable professionals
and he's also as a pity first year right
secondly okay so he has written a book
on AB strap as well he gives training to
people for instance in the City of
London he was just in New York giving a
training course to people in the New
York Stock Exchange type people banks on
using F sharp so so Thomas is giving a
tutorial on a sharp tomorrow at five
o'clock okay so you know if you want to
know more and particularly kind of do
technical deep dive then please do come
along you know it's great we ran out an
F shot workshop at the University of
peas are just last week with a hundred
people about 50 students and that was
great fun as well so so a lot of
technical deep dive really tomorrow with
Thomas and I but I'm trying to just give
you a bit of a flavor may need to get
you to go to this tutorial quite frankly
and but also to explore this so so when
we think about writing software okay so
how many of you are doing kind of
computer science software those computer
science PhD in a pretty hardcore formal
methods verification that kind of thing
so few of you okay how many of you doing
more applied stuff maybe like biology
environmental science something like
that okay how many of you doing
something in between all right how many
you don't know what you're doing yet
okay me right okay so but yeah you've
all kind of I guess written some
software at some point in your lives and
they're there are problems to suffer
right one of the things is typically we
don't just write software for the fun of
it some people do hands up who write
software for the fun of it okay some
people do which is really cool okay
hands up who writes software to actually
kind of do a particular task get some
results do something okay so that's most
of you okay so typically when we think
about software development we're trying
to get something done we're trying to do
something in a business sense this is
called time to market okay so if you're
a company okay so you're a startup and
you're trying to get into the
marketplace you want to get into the
marketplace as quickly as possible some
some other person doesn't beat you to it
so typically we would call that time to
market here i've called it getting
things done in a more research since the
other thing is efficiency so when i run
my code typically i want it to run fast
right typically i want it to run
infinitely flask so i just get the
answer like that sometimes that's not
possible so efficiency speed of
execution is clearly important
correctness is important okay so this is
kind of people don't always think of
this but it kind of if you don't have
this the first two things don't happen
right if you have bugs in your code okay
you're not getting your stuff done you
can run the code okay so i could run the
code really really fast but if i get the
wrong answer that's not particularly
useful so correctness is actually
vitally important okay and if i don't
have correctness at the outset when i
initially write my code that just means
i have to do a lot of debugging okay
complexity is an interesting one so if i
am trying to build a model for something
often i want to build in as many
features as I can into that model and
that model gets more and more complex
and so in in whatever software language
for instance that I'm using I want to be
able to capture complexity in an easy
way that I can understand is a human
being ok so I can translate into
software so these are four things that's
a vitally important for any software
okay
so if I boil that down what's the knee
so developers software developers
programmers okay what you really want to
be doing is developing correct software
okay so software that gives the right
answer okay that's a good start I want a
fish and software so i get the answer
quickly okay i want to be able to
deliver that software on time okay so i
actually want to be able to deliver my
finished software so if i'm doing my PhD
typical i do my PhD I spent about a year
trying to get this correctness stuff
done okay because I was translating
software from a language called Oakham
okay which is a parallel computing
language into c plus MP I message
passing interface to me about a year to
do that because it was horrendously
complicated or is all a synchronous and
horrible and so I kept running it and
having to run all these d bugs and
things so correct code but on time is
kind of actually getting results it took
me like a year before actually had any
results ok which was immensely
frustrating I wasn't using a sharp i was
using off Kevin C F sharp attempts as a
language and a paradigm to deliver that
in a very elegant way not just F sharp
though so functional languages
functional first languages by design
okay will generate simple correct and
robust code okay so typically in a
functional language okay we have
functions we have values which are
immutable so I can't change them so in a
function I can have lots of inputs go
into the function i get one output ok
but i don't change things outside of the
function so i can unit test the function
once I've written the function and I've
tested inputs give me these outputs
that's it done it will always work the
order in which i call that function in
relation to other functions doesn't
break it ok in imperative languages like
C sharp or Java ok I have to do this
testing regime and if I flip the order
of execution I could actually break the
function ok so that's where functional
language then again yeah all functional
languages do this ok so this is kind of
just at the core of a functional
language f sharps interesting as an
interoperable language the f sharp is
part of the dotnet fan
their languages so how many of you use
net c sharp that kind of thing okay so f
shop is a.net language so from a sharp i
can call c sharp and from c sharp i can
call F sharp okay and I get the full
stack going up and down errors etc well
that means as I can sort of seamlessly
build a piece of F sharp code into my
solution so if i have a million lines of
C sharp code to do all sorts of fancy
stuff often it's things like you I and
that kind of thing if I need to do for
instance some core mathematics or some
core kind of pulling stuff from the web
I can write a component in F sharp and I
can bed that in my etsy shop code and
seamlessly talk to it and so what that
means is if I have a large solution so
typically an f-sharp it's used in big
investment banks they have huge you know
trading floor software and things like
that the f shops really good at certain
things and they can just slide that in
and so an interoperable language and not
all functional languages are as
interoperable as f sharp you know this
is pretty cool if I have an
interoperable language it also means
that I can eliminate an entire phase of
development so some so uh how many
people use our ok so r is like
statistical language package okay so a
lot of companies typically all
researchers you write some our code r is
is really cool it's single thread in
32-bit ok not super faster everything so
what can often happen is I was really
good for prototyping ideas and stats and
things like that when actually say I
writes my code and I want to run like a
million instances of that right if the
fact that that's a bit slow can affect
you know when i get my results okay so
what typically can happen is for
instance in a bank they would take our
code and they get a team of developers
to convert it into c sharp and that
might take a couple of months okay
similarly Mathematica how many of you
use Mathematica a few view very good you
know mathematical piece of software and
again you don't really want to run that
in production so I spoke to one bank and
they said well you know our cones right
in Mathematica and then we need to
deploy on to a hundred thousand machines
okay that's a lot licensing costs for
Mathematica so what they do is they
actually convert it
c++ again they said that takes about
three months okay with F sharp what's
interesting is f sharp has in nice
characteristics in terms of being able
to program stats and maths but when you
compile it you've immediately got dotnet
code that runs fast okay in fact it's
comparable to see sure up in Java okay
sometimes it can goes faster C++
depending how the compiler can actually
streamline that code that can be so
efficient see here is is really
important and what it means as well as
that the functional languages in the way
we think about decomposing a problem is
funky it's quite mathematical okay
mathematicians think functionally and
therefore I can tackle and decompose a
complex problem I used to teach first
year computing to engineers who some of
them never touched a computer before ok
well now typically they use word and
powerpoint how do you then teach them
how to solve partial differential
equations using a finite difference
method on a computer right it's quite a
big step and a lot of it is actually
translating mathematics into computer
code into a number of statements or as
functional programming is much more
about how do I translate a mathematical
function into a computational function
and it's a much more seamless transition
ok so functional first thinking okay
plug for Thomas's book real world
functional programming is kind of
interesting in terms of it it teaches
functional programming but also with C
sharp examples as well as F sharp and
has some nice features ok so think so I
would encourage you as people starting
out to at least look at functional
programming ok we have this F sharp to
tour tomorrow to expose you to that but
other things so some paint Jones is
giving a couple of talks and of course
Haskell the Glasgow Haskell compiler is
essentially comes out of this lab as
well so again yeah think about
functional programming yeah
many more how do you mean yeah yeah it's
full yet or lambda calculus yeah yeah
and actually some of the things in
c-sharp have come from F sharp so
generics for instance dotnet generics
have come out of c sharp i'll show you
some examples of a sink paola have come
out of F sharp some people say if you
want to see what C sharp looks like in
three years look at F sharp today okay I
have it's interesting in terms of tech
transfer I was chatting to dong just
just the other day saying what's
interesting is you know Don has an idea
or people have an idea about after out
we can get into their sharp and push it
through and it suddenly appears into F
sharp product and then people sort of
get visibility of it so so it's kind of
interesting like say I'll show you the
stuff on information rich programming
and type providers and yeah a lot of
people like I'll that'd be really cool
in c-sharp so so yeah yeah it all gets
compiled down into the same intermediate
language bytecode right then so I mean
yeah that the sort of one of the things
with F was interesting is you know
making it a dotnet language so it was
designed from the ground up as a dotnet
language okay so so you know F sharp
came along after dotnet say so in the
design of the language you know Don
could make sure and the people on the
team could make sure that it will mesh
together really nicely whereas you know
if you took a functional language that
came before dotnet then you know you get
a bit more of an impedance mismatch so
that's why the sort of timing around
this is I guess that's right commerce
yeah yeah I guess
Berman's if you use some functional
abstraction in f-sharp then you would
have to use some other structure in
c-sharp to ride the code and often the
thing that I sharp does that it compile
some tongs will construct is that it
generates something that you would write
by hand as an object-oriented
abstraction so often the code is quite
similar at the isle compiled level well
there's there separately some overhead
with certain features but it means you
can solve the problem with pipelines
instead of objects so yeah but then yeah
sometimes you have to you have to maybe
switch to the imperative style in that
shower but that's usually more like
optimization at the end so I think this
is where there's the interoperability is
interesting it's not like if you were
using a functional language was not in
trouble you have to make a hard choice
and say I can only use this language
with F sharp you can kind of mix and
match even you know with vb you could do
a mixed solution some stuff and V
because V V is good at that and actually
I'm scared of that so that's why I think
you know don't think of F sharp is like
oh I need to just you know switch
everything to F sharp it should just be
another part of your toolkit okay and
you know some things will be beautiful
in f-sharp and some things just make
more sense in c-sharp but if you
actually have knowledge of both you can
kind of mix some action that can make
you much more productive in kind of
whatever you're doing so does that make
sense yeah
yeah sure I mean like so you know this
is about thinking functionally so
whatever you know talk to side when you
know about Haskell you know we love
Haskell in the lab so obviously that's
why we kind of still push Evan the GHC
so so I think that's you know I'm sort
of focusing enough shop a little bit
here but you know that I think the thing
is like filings you find this but you
know functional programming just makes
you productive right in whichever one
you know Skarloey as much more sort of
built on the Java stack okay but it's a
bit more than functional in its designs
okay so what is f sharp so it is a
functional first language of cake it's
open source okay so you can download it
Thomas has done some work where he's
taking the open source compiler and done
some research on top of it so as a
research language you can actually
download it and modify a cake so this is
pretty interesting yeah actually Thomas
is one of the attendants at the summer
school and he's also working with us oh
okay
friday evening wednesday even over see
ya tomorrow so you look tomorrow evening
on a sharp so you have the opportunity
to learn more yeah so so as with many
functional languages here is an example
of just if I'm commanding so Mars rover
and here's how I might write it you
could probably write it more elegantly
in c-sharp but you can see f shops quite
nice it uses white space instead of
braces for instance so we can make quite
clean code again functional data so if
I've got we have two pools okay and so
this is using the.net generics and
c-sharp for a fully generic tuple but
you can see how you know the F chart can
be can be quite an elegant way of
writing code there are some trends in
software okay the web the internet this
thing this I don't know if it's a fad
but it's my guess going to stick around
for a while multi-core parallel
programming okay I my PhD was in power
programming you know basically it's a
nightmare right so parallel programming
multi-core you know as I was at a
conference last week high performance
computing with all the people who
basically owned the biggest computers in
the world so that the biggest computer
in the world now is in the US and it has
guess how many calls it has just shoot
100,000 any Pudden keep going 1.5
million course okay 16 petaflop ok yes
machine actually interesting at the the
the conference they were talking about
exascale case there's a thousand
petaflop we estimate by 2018 2019 okay
it was interesting talking about that in
terms of just what's the mean time to
failure of memory okay if you have a
machine with that many cause and you
have that much RAM okay memory fails
right there's a mean time to failure for
a memory chip if you have that many if
you're running your code you're pretty
much guaranteed to have a memory failure
how do you saw how do you code to that
yeah how do you do fault tolerance okay
so it's kind of interesting so this
whole multi-core going from you know you
know laptops now shipping with quad-core
phones you know if it was like
in quad core right and then data okay so
f sharp has a sink which is pretty cool
so I can do grab some webpages and then
I can just run that asynchronously so it
so it pulls through again parallel CPU I
can do this Luke compute these tasks and
I can say run asynchronously and bang
it's just doing it in a couple of lines
coda cases some quite nice features
there this is really cool units of
measure okay so units are important okay
ah say I'm an aerospace engineer or so
interestingly to teach students we used
to set exam questions and imperial units
ok feat slugs that kind of thing because
if you work in the US on any aerospace
project you're going to use feet inches
slugs etc ok the u.s. uses imperial
units for everything not meters ok
luckily they still use hours minutes and
seconds but you know probably not by
choice so just units are important ok so
sta I was this Ronald raining experiment
two basic build a huge laser start it
was as cool star wars the laser that
could shoot down missiles okay nuclear
missiles so the experimental plan was
stick a big laser on a big mountain in
Hawaii track the space shuttle okay and
see if we can use the laser to hit the
space shuttle had a little mirror on the
bottom of it so that was plan what
actually happened was they stuck the
laser up there and they programmed the
autopilot on the space shuttle and this
happened okay and it didn't work and
this is the reason okay so basically
they sent up instructions to the space
shuttle and said okay make sure that the
mirror is pointing downward to spot
10,000 feet above sea level when
actually the guidance system was
expecting it in nautical miles and so
rather than pointing the mirror down
tend to that point 10,000 feet it was
pointing the mirror to a point ten
thousand nautical miles above the earth
and so
the space shuttle or over they
eventually fixed it but the issue was in
fact they just used the wrong units okay
the computer was expecting units of
nautical miles the people programmed it
thinking it was in feet okay another
example NASA lost lost and Mars orbiter
again because some people were using SI
units and some people were using
imperial units okay so it's a bit
embarrassing when you lose 125 million
dollar spacecraft okay so let's just got
to do with F shop so a shelf has unit so
we can assign a unit to a variable and
then the software can then verify that
all of the units are consistent okay and
so this is for instance why if you're a
bank you can have currencies okay and so
this is kind of built into the compiler
built into the system and this is
something that people really really like
okay so units of measure is pretty cool
this is the paper if you want to
actually read andrew kennedy upstairs
did the work on this in terms of a okay
well how do we build units of measure
into a programming language okay so
there is some real research in the lab
that's gone through into the product as
ken was saying as a tech transfer into
the product and now for instance you
know lots of people using units of
measure particularly sort of planks
really like it i'm the only dealing with
lots of different currencies for
instance you know you want to be able to
verify that software see so yeah yeah
yeah you can put your own so it ships I
think with SI units as a standard
library and then year you can extend it
with whatever you want so you can define
a value and then you can assign units to
it and you can assign different units so
like say banks will typically assign all
different currencies for instance to
different units and so you can imagine
if you're doing calculations your rank
some complex code for stock markets and
that type of thing or you know
particularly foreign exchange
commodities you know you want to make
sure you're getting the currencies right
and you don't have some error in your
algorithm wearing it's actually flipping
units and you don't know safe so it's
some yeah so some examples of where
people have used particularly F sharp
Powergen
essentials company that controls a lot
of the UK electricity grid okay and so
they had it they need to do load
balancing across the UK national grid
and what's interesting assignment
cousins here as they you know it's quite
a complex project they rolled out the
software and he waited a week and he
didn't get any phone calls didn't get
any bug reports so got on the phone to
all the people around the country and
said you didn't install my software did
you you didn't roll out the update and
they said no we did they just weren't
any bugs ok so it shows how you know
doing sort of lack of bugs ok so there's
type checkers for instance the unit
testing ok the other interesting thing
is exploratory programming so you'll see
the session try sharp it's just
interactive console so it's a ripple
console so I can type something run the
command and see what comes out and I can
very quickly experiment ok so that's
built into F sharp in Visual Studio to
let you up interactive and also in the
tryout console so that's quite nice
again units of measure just got rid of a
whole class of errors that they were
previously seeing parallelism so it just
shows how you know it's really helped
these folks and again how many views
Python yeah so again this company it's a
biotech company doing genome stuff and
you know they just thought you know
they've switched to F sharp now it's
quicker to develop quick to run they
really like it again the units of
measure just meant they could find a bug
really quickly so again E&F shops not
the only solution in the world but here
you can see where it's some people have
found it quite useful ok f sharp used
yeah
python yeah it depends what you doing
depends what libraries are using right
if you're using a massive library of the
Intel math kernal library then you're
pretty much going at the machine speed
anyway so you can do that in f-sharp as
well and you can use the Intel math
kernal library and say so does for this
application which these guys were using
okay that's why they saw I mean it's so
this is this is their business right
these guys have a company and they're
using Python to make money and they
switch so it's for their problem right
so yeah it's it's yeah it's a case study
right their problem they were doing
stuff in Python it ran this fast for
whatever I was pipeline for doing
ginamarie sequencing okay so you could
argue that maybe these guys weren't
writing that Python code is fast but
these guys were in it to make money so
I'm assuming that they actually had some
smart people who were trying to do the
job you know best of their kid okay say
so yeah so the development time now as
well is something that you know
obviously some features in there and
again you know this kind of thing you
know you can spend a week chasing a bug
right so you know it's a different
things in here but again this is you
know this is real world this is not
theoretical experiment these guys are in
business right so these guys this bottom
line helps to make more money and that's
that's this case study okay so these are
we have multiple case ID lots of
different case studies where people have
used it and again not just F shopping
other people are finding functional
programming is kind of on the rise now
in terms of people are finding that the
functional programming particularly for
development and robust code is a good
thing ok so the ice tea Python Python
saucer break another thing Python get in
visual studio bang so but but yeah again
it's an example right a lot of it comes
down to libraries and where libraries
you're using and lake see there's good
code and bad code right I'm assuming
that these guys right
code because they don't know these guys
but it's a company right if they write
bad code there be our business see this
is my sumption so that makes sense you
don't believe me do you item that it's
running at the Mickey make you speak and
then you can't do it faster if you write
some like sequence processing in
fighting by hand you do lots of
boxing of values like it sparking
everything as a reference it was in that
bad things like writing your own complex
algorithms in I do is probably going to
be slower but usually you can express
everything with mum by then yeah so I
think the key thing here is really I
think vias PhD students is I mean often
you use the language that your
supervisor tells you to use right
because certainly I as a supervisor
would maybe you feel a bit uncomfortable
if my student was writing stuff that I
can read okay so there is kind of
passing down of you or so in the
department I was in in aerospace
probably eighty percent of the code was
in Fortran okay fortran 77 1490 okay and
this was code that we shipped to airbus
for designing airplanes right so it's
often you use whatever code you're ill
talk to use what i would say here is
particularly as early petty so you
should just have a toolkit with lots of
things in okay certainly Python should
be piece of that tool kit you know
java.net you know you should you should
be able to use anything and you should
be able to make the choice of what the
best tool is for the job but if you
don't have experience of the wide tool
set and only you know i'm using a hammer
and i should be using a screwdriver
thing ya say so again you know and if
you're doing this actually what you
should do is just do the benchmark right
pull out a kernel of what's taking all
the time see what what works best right
say good question
in the lab here we have a team that
actually works for Bing okay and does
the ad ranking okay so this helps with
the auctioning of ads okay and so most
of their code is actually written in
f-sharp okay and again they just find it
useful for prototyping okay it's a nice
language for that but again the units of
measure comes into this as well so again
it's just another example of where you
know this kind of functional approach
kind of works really nicely okay so
that's kind of where this functional
first thinking think of it as functional
first thinking where f sharp is an
instantiation of that and there are
other instantiations which you know
maybe more or less appropriate okay so
you talked about speed so f core math
for instances GPU library fresh crops
such as Reitsma shopko and bang running
on GPU so there are lots of different
ways again you can use F sharp as part
of that toolkit for any particular
solution that you're that you're using
ok I'm going to talk about F sharp three
now just to end up onto a data
integration which were really super
excited about and then how many of you
heard of agile right whew so how many of
you heard of cloud computing how many of
you heard of Amazon Web Services how
many of you heard is google cloud
alright as they announced some stuff
last week so Asher is our cloud thing
okay and F sharp plays quite nicely with
that okay because you know Microsoft
stack we try and make sure that things
work well together and so again you can
you can you can do a lot of great things
a lot of great things with that and this
is some stuff we're actively doing that
so hopefully that's a kind of quick
canter through around some things around
functional thinking functional
programming and how you know F sharp is
one way you can do that so I want to go
on to now this new line of thinking
with a shop which is this information
rich programming so the fundamental kind
of observation is we now live in an
Information Society okay so in the old
days okay when we were cavemen and cave
women what we do is we would grab a
spear we'd go out we go and hunt okay
grab an animal we go home feed the
family okay then this agricultural
revolution came along we discovered how
to domesticate animals how to farm how
to grow crops okay and so he moved from
this hunter-gatherer society into this
agricultural society okay then okay we
could essentially make that really
really easy to do and we came up with
this idea of making machines okay so we
could build things and we could build
you know furniture and houses and cars
and airplanes ok so that was this
industrial revolution okay so we we
basically moved to making stuff okay and
so more recently we're kind of in the
middle of this information revolution
we're particularly the web has broken
open information a case of the printing
press famously made knowledge much more
widely available okay previously people
would have to hand write books and
they'd be distributed so like monks and
monasteries would distribute Bibles for
instance the printing press kind of
production eyes that so we could have
newspapers and things we could
disseminate information very quickly
okay so that was kind of the star of the
information revolution now
electronically we can immediately
instantly disseminate information okay
so this is creating this new revolution
of you know shrinking the world making
information very readily available so
it's kind of where it's a very very
interesting exciting time to be alive
one could argue that programming
languages were not designed for that
they were designed for an industrial age
okay and so languages from the ground up
were not really designed to integrate
information at it scores sort of
first-class citizen information in the
sort of internet websites okay and so if
we want a program against that you know
people have come up with ways of doing
that okay JSON and stuff
that but again we have this friction
okay accessing information you have to
go through these api's and interfaces
and and when I'm actually coding I can't
just pull stuff in to the language okay
so this is a major major problem as we
were in this information revolution and
more and more of the software rewrite
and web apps phone apps you know tablet
apps etc need to integrate this
information okay and it's a big big
problem okay we can solve the problem
using the existing tool kit okay which
again one could argue was designed for a
different age or we could look at okay
well how do we change our language
design in order to you know replay well
in this sort of sea of information and
that's where you know the work that
Don's been doing in the f-sharp team has
been trying to just experiment say okay
how might we do that and so the solution
today that they sort of come up with is
what we call type providers and you know
you could have done this other languages
but the reason that we use F sharp is
because we have control languages of the
language we have type inference ok we
have strong typing we have good tooling
visual studio we have the interop okay
we have things like link so this is so
tied providers is the again an
experiment really in how do we you know
think about language design in an
information-rich society and what a
tight provider does is it compile time
it basically can go into an information
space pull back the schema and the
metadata for that information space and
make it available to the developer right
at the in the IDE okay the data the
information is not pulled in okay but
it's a pipe where we can suck suck all
those data and services in to the
language itself so it doesn't contain
the data it's extensible so you can
write your own tie provider there are
some that ship out of the box okay so an
example of this is the World Bank so the
World Bank publishes a whole bunch of
data
it's great there's this big revolution
in open data okay governments are
pushing out more and more of their data
okay in the gov in the UK there's open
data to you k in the US and Australia
Brazil okay there's a push for
transparency pushing data out okay so
you get a world bank website and there's
lots of these different indicators okay
and you can and there's an API for that
and you can look through documentation
and you can access all of those AP is
now the type provider mechanism and this
is an example and the type file is
actually Thomas's piece of work is what
i can do is i can activate the type
provider and a dll okay and then once
I've activated it what I do is I just
access World Bank dot and what's this is
pulling the schema back from the world
back website and pushing it straight
into intellisense inside Visual Studio
oopsie you want to do that I wanted to
continue playing okay and then so I do
that so I say okay well I want to now
drill down and explore this information
space so I do well bank ID dot I guys is
interesting so I have country say okay
dot so I do dot and it's now pulled back
the list of countries from the world
bank's site and I can browse through
that information space I can go dot and
i can now this is really interesting say
wow okay so I now have access to
hundreds of different data sets in there
okay and what's interesting is it's
pulling back the metadata so clearly
this is all available in some
documentation somewhere but here I don't
have to do that I just do dot bang it's
in visual studio okay so i can eat so i
can explore the information space okay
so what that means is it makes it much
nicer for me as a developer to go
through and actually pull back this data
ok so the type provider again is enables
me to pull that back in previously to do
that I'd have to do some koj and it will
be quite static and and here it's trying
to make that Reese seamless okay and so
here we're going to just pull back the
greek national debt
k as a percentage of its gdp okay you
can see it's like a hundred and forty
percent of its gdp so that's one set of
data but now it's interesting is now I
can just now I know like so I want to
compare that with some other countries
so I can go and pull back some other
countries and then immediately just hit
you know this is just some formatting
for the chart hit bang and it's going to
the World Bank and it's pulling back all
that data okay through the API and you
can see why Greece is in trouble because
it's national debt is quite a lot worse
than other countries but hopefully you
can see there how the type provider
mechanism allows me to pull back the
data like over the web okay another
example here is with some climate data
so there's a there's a file format
called netcdf which is a binary format
where pretty much all climate data and
weather data is people distribute it
okay so it's a very compact binary
format because it's a binary format it's
a little bit opaque so we brought I
provider that allows me to pull that
netcdf in this is firing up just a tool
called dataset viewer so this is a
visualization tool so I'm pulling in
this data set and so I can do CIU dot
and then again it's pulling together the
schema is giving me a lot lat lat and
long and monthly data etc and then I can
immediately pull that back and you'll
see then it it plots an area of the UK
with some temperature data basically so
I'm going to pull that through and do
the visualization into the dataset
viewer and you can see here it shows
your contour map then of the monthly
average temperature in the UK from this
big chunky nasty binary data file okay
and you can see the schema comes up
there so that's interesting the other
thing is Microsoft has this thing called
the actual data marketplace on the cloud
you can go date marketplace in there are
hundreds of different data sets up there
it's essentially an area where you can
share data okay the UK Met Office so
we're Scarlets weather forecast came
from publishes its five-day forecast on
30 intervals every three hours on that
website and so here what we're using is
the actual data marketplace type
provider we're going out to there and
we're pulling back now essentially
the weather forecast for weather
stations around the UK and then we're
actually applying a little bit of
processing on that to compare that with
the 50 year average for that point okay
and this is the Delta between what's the
average over 50 years at each one of
these points and you'll see the dots
coming up as it's pulling the data
through from the actual data marketplace
that's essentially the weather forecast
data so it shows how we can use the type
provide a mechanism to pull data from
different places and then just be able
to do some different mathematics around
that so hopefully that shows you why
this type provide a mechanism or how it
kind of makes that really nicely smooth
why is that important because of this
you gotta ProgrammableWeb it shows you
all the open API is available over the
web okay from sort of 2000 okay what's
interesting is if you plot the numbers
is it's pretty exponential okay so what
it means is this ability to pull
information from the web into the
language right to the developers
fingertips is becoming more and more and
more important okay and that's where
this experiment with F sharp is taking
us as you know can we really make that
you know reality so lots of different
applications for Thai providers okay for
we done a type provider for an Excel
spreadsheet for instance you can pull
spreadsheet data in social data there's
a great demo on the web if you go and
see it if you do a search on like Donald
Syme SYM e-type provider great Twitter
example where you can just pull the live
Twitter stream through and then apply
use F sharp to apply filters in real
time against it so lots of different
examples again it's extensible it's open
you can write your own type providers so
just want to finish up in terms of
functional first thinking so not just F
sharp okay so o camel haskell scholar
etc it's really nice paradigm something
you know encourage you to explore in
whichever language you're most
comfortable with and again we've got
tutorial tomorrow if you want to play
around with a sharp and again you know
when you go out for jobs afterwards you
know again this functional programming
is becoming more and more prevalent as
system has become more complex software
systems become more complicated
okay and so f sharp itself just in
summary you know has some nice features
but again we're focusing on the future
which is web data and cloud so tutorial
session tribe trap is where you can
actually learn f sharp announced for
Thomas will be using tomorrow f sharp
net is the main microsoft a shockwave
side see thank you very much sorry I'm a
bit sick if you've spoken a lot about
the correctness of F sharp in my
experience in commercial development
memory managed systems dealt with a lot
of the problems that people had with
managing memory but most of the bugs
that we found were from locking and from
new texts and getting those things wrong
whereas all of the examples of
parallelism that you've so far shown
have been embarrassingly parallel we
don't actually have to worry about
locking or any of those sorts of things
so just wondering does if shall provide
anything above and beyond that other
languages or other tools don't with
regards to getting locking and
parallelism that's not embarrassing
power Berra singh lee parallel correct
so here i was talking about the sort of
a sink mechanism like you say which is
slightly different to what you were
talking about so i guess in terms of
correctness and locking i guess when
you're doing locking it's trying to
making sure things don't interfere with
each other right as variables pass
through and in out board or a different
order and so I guess the functional
paradigm just helps because those
functions don't change variables outside
so you can architect your solution in a
month you can sort of think about how to
architect that parallel solution in a
more robust way so you start to think
hard about how to actually make this
work in order is that a fair assumption
the level you have you okay there's my
car oh oops spark it thanks so there's
um something which is in don't let which
is called taskbar ll library which is
like task-based library for doing
parallel programming which is kind of
similar to the Haskell parmo not if
you're familiar with that so that's that
the bikes one functional way then
there's something based on the actor or
agent-based model which is like airline
based programming model based on message
passing so that's another option and you
can also use locking if you're really
sure that that's what you want to do in
the industry i guess most of the case
studies that came she mentioned like the
young data processing they were building
on the actor model based on message
passing wishes i find it personally
easier model to work with and it's
getting quite popular in languages like
airlines and scala but you have you have
choice of different options which I
guess relates to the fact that you can
interoperate with dot net which has some
libraries and with some F sharp specific
things as well yes it's not a magic
bullet I think one of the things that if
your code is easier to read then you can
kind of assemble more assemble the
solution in a clear way it helps you
think through the problem I think the
parallel program is still hard and again
the task parallel libraries an attempt
by Microsoft to make it easier but it's
the dotnet level so you have access to
that right I guess at a point that I'm
trying to make is that most bugs that we
found were due to parallelism bugs
getting locking right with a some sort
of shared state that multiple processes
need access to and getting those things
right actually was the source of most of
our bugs
so with regards to robustness the
language doesn't seem to provide some
kind of solution to that problem not
that I'm suggesting that the necessarily
is one but not that that that was the
main problem that we faced with regard
to with code robustness yeah I mean
shared state saw was yeah tough to
manage but again I think here there's a
set of tools that that maybe make it
easier to see how to manage that state
but yeah I said parallel program was
still stood I guess it gives you more
programming models so you can choose one
that doesn't rely that heavily unlocks
and shared state and then it's easier to
deal with it thank you are there any
other questions thank you first of all
for the great presentation he and I have
a question about the today question yeah
each of us has different operation
systems some of us has microsoft windows
other has linux and my cause what about
a sharp will it work on different
operation system or it is only logged
for windows so f sharp shapes with
visual syria which runs on windows but
it the open-source drop runs on linux
and mac OS as well so it's not using use
linux or mac then maybe not but you know
hopefully we have all the bases covered
so the open-source drop actually has
that rice as Linux compiler and I think
it works in monodevelop right so works
in monodevelop as well what about mobile
devices is it also so you can program
you can program windows phones I think
but I'm not sure so it's you can use it
with XNA ok so you program xbox and you
can program windows phone with it as
well for non Microsoft operating systems
I'm not too sure ok thank you ok so it's
ready to write mobile applications
osprey and there are a few projects that
translate f sharka javascript so you can
write code in a chart and that it will
run everywhere but that's still in kind
of early / research phase I said it's an
interesting pirate okay yeah so that's
this will put you switched out for
decking yeah a related question to that
M so you talked about an open source
drop is that a one-time-only thing or
are you going to try and build a bit of
more community around now we're
committed to open source drops a shark
3.0 will also be with the type providers
partly open source drop and it's on
github right yes it's on github no way
one quick comment I know it's
complicated when you ask questions to
speak into the phone and of course to
the speaker but also make sure that the
rest of the audience can you follow us
one for saying so then we can all follow
up follow the discussion yeah good
question so I will thank you very much
and hope you enjoy the week Cheers